Del wire has a reported that GOP Leed
House Began on Friday to release tens of
thousands of hours of video footage from
January 6th 2021 the day of the US
capital breach to the public speaker
Mike Johnson who is less than a month
into the job announced the rolling uh
disclosure of more than 40,000 hours of
footage to a website his office said the
footage will not include a small portion
of video that may contain sensitive
security information or information that
could lead to retaliation against
private citizens uh Johnson said in a
post to x uh quote to restore America's
Trust and faith in their government we
must have transparency this is another
step towards keeping the promises I made
when I was elected to be your speaker
some Republican lawmakers and others
have long pressed for the release of
security footage of the day when a crowd
of people entered the US capital uh but
of course those uh up until now people
urging for that disclosure have been
rebuffed um and now it's all being made
public now over the weekend a bunch of
uh of you know previously unreleased
videos started circulating um on social
media well on Twitter at least if
Twitter didn't exist or if Elon Musk
didn't own it then we could be pretty
sure that these videos uh we would not
see which is which is like another big
reason why it's emblematic of the reason
why the left wants to destroy Elon Musk
so um we'll take a look at one of the uh
this a couple of videos we'll take a
look at here's one where we could see
it's just basically a stream of people
kind of casually walking down the
hallway let's take a look at that
briefly okay now the people are
just you can see them just walking
casually down the hallway they've got
their
Flags the cops are standing
there they're
filming very very
casual and that's a and there's a lot of
videos like that um there's one other
before we talk about this there's one
other I want to show this one you can
see it's a u uh a protester is is being
let out in handcuffs but then the
handcuffs are taken off and he fist
bumps the officer and walks away let's
watch that
one okay there he is in the
Cuffs appears to be wearing some kind of
motorcycle helmet or
something they take the handcuffs off he
fist pumps the
guy and then that's
it prob they give him his bag
back and he walks
away all
right so uh what do we make of this well
there's there's a a reason why it took
them almost three years to release this
footage you know that's one thing we can
learn from it there was never any good
legitimate reason to not release it I'll
make the same argument I did with the uh
the Covenant shooter Manifesto it is not
the government's job to decide what
information we need to be told try and
we are very accustomed to the government
assuming that job that we we almost
would
think that this is one of the
government's fundamental jobs because
it's our entire lives this is how they
this is this is been their primary
function is to figure out what
information we should be told suppress
information this is this is not the
government's job transparency should be
the rule not the exception you know
unless it's a a case you know actual
clear-cut case of national security or
some other rare exception we should just
be told everything and this is
especially true because even if I agreed
that the state
should um or would be justified in
withholding information from us because
uh they don't want us to to draw
politically inconvenient conclusions
which of course I don't agree with that
but if I did people will draw those
conclusions if you don't tell them
everything and in this case whatever
they were worried about people thinking
about January 6th we already thought it
because they wouldn't show us the tapes
and now we see it it only confirms what
we already assumed we're facing the
threat of a potential government
shutdown and the administration will
ultimately deal with it the say way they
always do with more spending more
spending will inevitably devalue the
dollar protect your savings then by
diversifying into gold with the help of
Birch gold group when you open an IRA
with Birch gold for every $10,000 you
spend by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar just text wals
to 98 9898 to claim eligibility before
Black Friday Birch gold can even help
you convert an existing Ira of 401k into
an IRA in Gold without taking any money
out of pocket and you still get the free
gold bars with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
satisfied customers you can count on
Birch gold to help you transition an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
don't let your savings fall victim to
the further devaluation of the dollar
Texas walls to
9898917350 what was January 6 you can
see in all these videos it obviously was
not an Insurrection it was not a
terrorist attack um it is not a tragedy
on the level of 9911 it did not warrant
three years of hearings and trials and
Theatrical Productions not to mention
that in some cases you know you got
decades and Decades of prison time uh
didn't warn all that it was something
that in many
cases was mild enough that lots of these
people clearly didn't even think they
were breaking any
laws that's why they're walking casually
by these police officers in the hallway
if you think that you're breaking a law
it's that's that's not how you would
conduct
yourself I mean if I was there and I saw
people just being led into the Capitol
building and allowed to walk around
while COPS stand there and watch and
give them fist bumps um and also if I
was extremely naive so if all those
things were true I would probably assume
that okay I guess we're allowed to do
this now I'm not naive so I would have
known as I as I did on on the day when
this was happening and said so that
these people are walking into a trap
they're walking into something that's
going to destroy their lives but for a
lot of these people as the videos
clearly show um their crime was naiv
they they they that was it for a lot of
them not all of them but a lot of
them and whatever else you want to say
about it to call this an
Insurrection is just ridiculous like
what Insurrection in history could have
ever been confused with a guided tour
like this one if I showed you that video
and I without
context and I told you oh this is uh
some people going on a guided tour of
the capital you'd believe me you know if
you had no context at all you saw these
okay yeah well it's a big group of
people it's a little weird they have
flags that they're carrying but other
than that
sure so that's what I want to that's
what that that is what I ask you give me
another example of an insurrection
that you could pull like hundreds of
hours of video of the Insurrection
happening and if you didn't know any
better you would confuse it with a
guided tour of a government
building because that's what a lot of
this looked
like
um and so obviously what we're being
told about it is absurd hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use code Walsh to get two months
free on all annual plans see you there